[Applause]
home at last five Iranian Americans
touched down on U.S soil in early
morning Darkness on Tuesday the
completion of the final step of a
high-stakes deal between Iran and the
United States we take it for granted
having a family together we've been
apart for eight years and finally we're
together and it's just completely
unbelievable and we're grateful for this
moment Iran had accused the five dual
Nationals of spying the U.S says they
were wrongfully detained
the prisoners freed by Iran were
Wildlife conservationist Murad tabas
businessman emad sharghi and samak
namazi the longest held American in Iran
imprisoned for eight years the names of
the other two released Americans was
withheld by the U.S government per the
family's requests all five are said to
be in good health now back in the United
States they will have available to them
thorough medical evaluations and
services and be put through a security
debrief
in Tehran another Homecoming this time
for some of the Iranians released as
part of the deal
it was tougher for my family rather than
me it was a difficult situation for them
my mother right now is hospitalized due
to the pressure she was faced both sides
have been Keen to portray the swap as an
isolated incident
Iran
the prisoners swapped between Iran and
America was purely a humanitarian move
we believe that some people were
arrested here that didn't deserve to be
arrested and there were persons in Iran
with lawsuits against them the exchange
happened after 6
dollars of
events were
Trey had been blocked by the U.S U.S
officials say they will monitor Iran's
use of the money to borrow it for
nuclear or military development
the regime will never get to touch the
money they can make a request for
certain humanitarian products medical
supplies food Agricultural and then we
will supervise a process by which uh
fully qualified vendors will go procure
that material and then deliver it into
Iran in Washington Republican critics of
U.S President Joe Biden slammed the deal
as the U.S paying Ransom to hostage
takers Biden defended the deal as
putting American lives first he and
Iranian president Ibrahim raisi are both
attending the UN General Assembly in New
York this week both leaders have
downplayed the prisoner exchange while
some are hopeful this rare moment of
cooperation between Iran and the U.S
could offer a glimmer of hope for the
Revival of nuclear talks in the near
future
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera